can men be vulnerable with women
what's your tick
they
[Music]
depends what outcome you want and I
think a lot of times men are vulnerable
with their women and they think that
their women will look at them the same
and often they don't
at least that's what the men have said I
personally when I first started
listening to Red Pill content I was like
oh yeah you could talk to women like
and then I thought about I thought about
it long and hard and I'm like oh my God
it's crying all the time no do you want
a guy that's always constantly telling
me how how he feels no did it annoy me
when my ex would always be telling me
how he felt yes and so it's like we
don't even know what we want